good morning uh welcome to legislative
Administration uh can
we would you like to lead us in the
pledge
thanks
to the the United States of America and
to the republ for it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for
all first off I would like to welcome
our uh substitutes and guests for the
day um we have representative Malloy for
uh Stephanie
payer um representative
Fox for you had it backwards
representative payer and representative
conin sorry um
and we also have someone
missing um yep on the Republican side um
uh representative Maguire is uh um
substituting for um Mike costable
representative costable Y and uh Michael
Michael Vos is substituting for Pearson
oh yes stepen uh representative Pearson
um and then we have one
additional
absentee
no
um montio rep mon right
yeah okay AB
absent um great so thank you very much
for for helping us out um
representatives and welcome um hope not
to uh uh take up too much of your time
um we're dealing with two bills uh these
are
longstanding um retain bills that we've
had in the committee actually one of
them goes goes back to last term um
which is the first one uh House Bill
301 uh dealing with recusal for members
of the general court for conflicts of
interest um has everyone
received repan amendment to House Bill
301 that is
h I guess
not that would be
helpful um it was emailed out to
everyone
so and I
know I know we emailed it
to
um here's a hardup you got
one so how you
been
don't
know Jennifer's making copies but it
looks like everybody has one now
right oh oh There are some over there of
the original bills yeah but we don't we
need the amendment okay I'm sorry yeah
the amendment is replace all right Ander
renders it move
what but since this is an executive
session um I'm going to
first recognize um Vice chair Sheen um
for a motion
on um Senate Bill uh House Bill 301 yeah
I move a to pass um rep she and moves
ought to passes there
second rep sers um seconds and now we
get into the discussion phase um the
bill is open to to Amendment um
representative
Sheen would you like to offer an
amendment uh yes I would um would you
prefer that I wait till everybody gets a
copy um you can you can offer the
amendment and then we'll wait for the
amendment okay yes so I'd like to offer
the amendment and um you know as
chairman Hill stated earlier just just
make a motion to I I move to amend hb31
with amendment number 20
23-23
26h thank you uh we have
we have an amendment um available to us
to discuss now um perhaps we need a
minute or two before that's distributed
I will say that um this amendment is a
replace Hall as mentioned earlier and it
does come with
findings uh four of
them and the body of this amendment came
to us from the chair of Ethics um all of
the findings came to us from the chair
of Ethics um last year and and continued
to stay with us in the um retain Bill
process that points to why this is an
important piece of
legislation um and
then I think it's
clear
um you will see as you look through up
here we go as you look through the
amendment um a lot of the language will
be similar to what we saw in that
original Bill if you have
it but representative she would you like
to discuss your
Amendment
yes um so as chairman Hill stated
previously that this bill has been a
work in progress since last
term um we've studied how other
states uh handle recusal in their
legislatures um we've had help from the
research
department and um as well as the Ethics
Committee which 99% of the wording comes
from recommendations from the Ethics
Committee so we feel we have good
wording um strong wording that uh we've
got input by a number of uh sources and
we feel that you know this bill is ready
for Prime Time on the
floor thank you um would the ranking
member who also sits on ethics like
a quick comment or two uh good morning
Mr chairman members of the committee
I initially supported
this until I went to the Ethics
Committee and yes I am on the Ethics
Committee and with discussion in the
Ethics Committee I listened to what was
said uh former Speaker of the House Don
aitech was the first to speak who said
this is too broad it's not
enforcable it goes beyond in fact what
she said is enforceable and and the big
thing is it excludes too many people too
many members of the legislature and the
Ethics Committee felt it should be
narrowed down therefore the Ethics
Committee voted against this particular
Amendment with the wording as
is um thank you um representative wall
did the Ethics Committee
mention
um the source of of the language in this
yes the source of the language was
definitely mentioned um they recognized
that uh again the members of the
committee just felt that it excluded too
many members from being able to vote in
the house that we needed to narrow it
down did the Ethics Committee offer
suggestions of how that could be
narrowed down the Ethics Committee said
respectfully that they would like this
committee to be able to look at it
further and see what they could do they
didn't feel that were in the position to
um draft
legislation thank you any further
comments representative sers yeah I have
a thank you Mr chair I have a question
as far as the ethic committee I know
they don't write legislation I get it
but did they have
suggestions actually they do write
legislation that's how we get the
original bill um was written by the
chair of I thought I just heard her say
that they did didn't write it
so yes represent I'd like to respond to
that sure um this has gone so far right
now that we're into the home stretch on
it and they felt that this committee had
a better handle on uh what should or
should not be included they they feel
that it goes too far in the terms again
of excluding too many members in terms
of the language and if we go through it
we can perhaps pick that out I don't
know what the committee prefers to do
thank you thank you um
so it was evident um at least to me from
the start that there were two ways to
draft legislation on this topic um one
was as the Ethics Committee gave us the
bill which was for
prosecutorial purposes um when when
someone had an Ethics complaint um filed
they would be able to use this language
um to match it up to what the complaint
was and and that's what the original
Bill
did um this
committee I'm not sure if it was last
year or the end yeah I think it was this
term um try to look at it more as an
advisory um piece of legislation so that
we could advise particularly newer
Representatives what was ad advisable
when when would be a good time for
someone to recuse themselves so that you
could avoid that complaint U arriving at
ethics um that was the piece that we
brought to the Ethics Committee um prior
to retaining this um during the normal I
think it was even after a
crossover um they didn't like that
version either because it gave them no
leeway um
from from that point on um all this
committee has done is um taken their
language that that they originally
requested and and that's what we sent
back to them yesterday uh for comment um
it was their language so um I'm not sure
if if um there's much that we can do
Beyond um giving them two options
neither of which they seem to have have
liked and one of those options was their
own language back so um representative
thank you very much Mr chairman I I
really appreciate and agree with what
you have said um I it's my belief that
the Ethics Committee would prefer to go
back even though they didn't state it
it's and during the short discussion
they had on this amendment yesterday
they preferred seemed to have preferred
the simpler language that uh chairman
Ned Gordon had had in the beginning
which um defined when someone should
recuse for conflicts of interest and
defines uh direct
Financial uh benefit and that's about it
that's the difference it it simplifies
it brings it right down
uh thank
you I think the language before
us is Ned Gordon's language represent uh
chairman Gordon's language the only
thing that has been
changed Was the removal of an
additional definition that of special
interest
um and the reason special interest was
removed was it didn't seem to um Define
anything it only gave us an additional
definition to have to weed through um
you'll see on line 27 of page
two um con it the original language said
conflict of interest means the condition
in which a legislator has a special
interest and we've changed that to a
financial interest or a non-financial
personal interest both of those things
were already defined as special interest
in the original
language
so
um they had in the original Bill special
interest defined as means any Financial
or non-financial personal interest in
the outcome of a matter that is the
subject of offici activity distinct from
and greater than the interests of the
public at
large that's what was
removed in response um I understand what
you're saying Mr chairman um disclosure
of conflicts of interests in the
amendment um I'm going from the original
draft I don't I didn't look at the
amendment to see exactly where it comes
in um but talks about anyone acting as
counsel or serving as an attorney for
any party which has a conflict of
interest in the official legislative
activity and that has been added from my
understanding um where is that now I'm
looking at just the original draft that
was given to
me can you point to a line or I'm on for
the original draft on
roman3
oh here it is so be line 18 line 18 I'm
sorry what was we can't hear
representative wall very well I will
bring this closer turn it on yeah well I
had it on but I did I had it too far
away thank line 18 did you say yeah I
have it on line 18 of what page on page
two uh acting as Council serving as
attorney for any party that has conflict
of
interest
um
that there was a comment about
that again there was no big discussion
on this I mean almost instantly um the
former Speaker of the House said it's
too broad it it it's almost
unenforceable rep yes representative
McGuire uh two comments really that part
about acting as Council which has a
conflict of interest in the official
legislative activity isn't that already
forbidden by our constitution yes so we
don't need to reiterate it in the
legislation because it's in the
Constitution and the other thing is that
the current
definitions allow for a great deal of
interpretation U for example when we're
voting on
the education Freedom accounts or the
tax credit
scholarships some people who families
are involved in the program recuse
themselves and some people don't because
they say Well it affects everybody so I
think that having it clearer that in
such a case you should recuse yourself
will mean
that we need to give better guidelines
because otherwise people are going to
interpret it the way they
want thank
you representative wall I think that
does make sense one of the problems we
have is people people don't even look at
the ethics guidelines people don't seem
to know uh when they should recuse we'd
rather have more people recuse them not
in the interest of doing the right thing
and that is the problem getting people
to understand when and when they should
not recuse thank you for what you
said um I would like to point out that u
under the findings uh the number one
finding talks about part two article 7
of the New Hampshire Constitution no
member of the general court shall take
fees be of councel or act as Advocate or
any cause before either branch of the
legislature um and upon due proof
thereof such member shall forfeit his
seat in the legislature that's
almost
exactly
um the definition that they had problems
with
the question of course Mr chair is that
the if it's already you've already found
that it's in the constitution do we need
to reiterate that in in the statute or
is it
assumed um or are they not is it not act
actually being done and counter to that
if it's already in the Constitution
what's the harm in it being reiterated
okay representative sers I'm just
wondering on
um why not just point the Constitution
at that point could you know as
well
good
sense six of to me that's six of one
half dozen of another um if you point to
that section or you use the the
language from the Constitution yep
representative C yeah so as a new
legislator um I you can only use that in
the first year
by still the first year uh any case my
point is is that you know the
Constitution is is uh an area that I'm
not extremely wellous but getting better
with and if I if I look at a statue and
it's in there it it's pointing to a a
part one part two article then they said
oh okay that makes sense to me that's
all it just helps out for
clarity I I agree
um I
would if it were me and I waved my magic
W I would probably put both things in
there I would put the language and the
the um that section listed there um
showing where it came from
um the point being however
that if the organization that is to deal
with the prosecutorial part of this
um that's why we put the findings that's
why that that section is listed in the
findings to to show this is where where
you go for guidance if you need it as
the Ethics Committee um it's not it's
not this committee's job to um show the
ethics Comm comme how they are to
proceed and where they are going for
information
so any further comment representative
o thank you Mr chair I would just make a
quick comment about findings findings
end up in session law right which is
referred to during court cases
potentially to determine legislative
intent but it never appears in the
statute in chapter law so I don't see
any harm in making findings as extensive
as you can make
them with the idea being if a court ever
needs to refer to the findings to find
out what the legislative intent of the
legislation under question was uh they
can do that and and the more information
there the
better thank
you
yep thank you I I think what we were
referring to
is the
um the objection by the Ethics Committee
to the amendment as it's currently
written one of those items was the fact
that they were showing um counselors and
uh acting of as councel as
Advocate and yet
um the Ethics Committee should be aware
of what the Constitution says about
those
things in response yes this Ethics
Committee certainly is and again the
Ethics Committee didn't have great
discussion about this they had several
cases to deal with yesterday this was
the last thing on the docket and um very
very little discussion but the only
discussion or the only comments made
were one um that and I'll read what they
were
the concerns were um that it's too
broad that it excludes too many people
and it goes beyond what is reasonably
enforceable and those were the exact
words of those who
opposed any further
comment if you would like to ask for a
caucus
um we'll be in a brief few minute
caucus five minutes would be great um
that brings us back
at between 20 of and quarter
of
thanks
yeah I
yes
comment says shall we go to uh calling
the
role um Mr chairman we had the caucus
and and we had very respectful
discussion we are totally in agreement
with the
findings uh the concern is with the
recusal um and we have some
language uh that's a little bit narrower
on the recusal aspect and with that um
it narrows it down to two uh
specific options or situations where
someone should
recuse and so we have
a
draft of that for the recusal and we
respectfully asked if we can at least
have that looked at today are you have
you headed head already TOS or is this
it's it's they it doesn't have um an
amendment number it's just a draft this
a discussion yes that's all it is okay
well uh if you would like to propose
well can we pass this out then so people
can see thank
you you have enough that I think
so do you have enough going that
way um all all all that we were asking
for Mr chairman is a change in the
recusal section of the
bill
we're looking at lines I should point
out to everyone this is not um official
this is um just a type piece of a typ
it's only a draft only a draft for
consideration um and we're looking at
the recusal section which is uh lines 19
through 24 or 25 rather whatever to the
bottom of the page um page one yes yes
this page two
um we're keeping the same so under the
recusal section we're looking for two
specific
situations
um some of you may Rec remember when we
had former State Rep the late State Rep
Doug lay who was a member of this
committee and um he was being paid by I
think it was the education department I
forget exactly yeah that's what it was
thank you yet he was working here here
and voting and there were um concerns
about that and he eventually did start
recusing from voting but this became a
real situation because it was not clear
when he should recuse at least to him it
was not can can I ask what part of this
is new um which from line what to what
is we're looking at line 19 you
legislators shall recuse themselves from
voting on any legislation all the way to
line 23 um or is it beyond
that line through 23 so just that
paragraph is what we're talking about
right and yes no no no no it also goes
to the bottom of the page line
26 so sections one and two yeah
yeah and they're very similar to what we
have and what's been proposed by
representative Shan and again I I truly
respect all the work that's gone into
this it's it's been a tough project for
those who are deeply involved um and
that would replace on the
Amendments um everything from line
23 um
to to
what okay I haven't compared the two yet
um let's just take a
um in order here that again looking at
those of you who can remember the Doug
way situation um the language in in this
proposed I did not draft this we did
this is Ned Gordon former representative
n Gordon chairman n Gordon's
Amendment
um this this brings back the idea of
special interest as well
right
no remove
remove the wording that you originally
um weren't in favor of we were going to
remove that the special special interest
and the definition yes yes so so there's
a correction I guess then
on on page 20 on line 22 because that's
where special interest comes in so what
goes in place of as a special
interest representative Maguire yes
thank you I'm looking at this Roman one
and it appears to me that this is almost
exactly what's in 1B of the shean
amendment
and yeah I'm not sure what's different
yeah well it it's the difference as far
as I can tell is employed buyers acting
as an agent
whereas for this organization rather
than has a responsibility for the
welfare of the organization it seems
like it would broaden it rather than if
you're just an employee rather than a
fiduciary right yeah I mean if you're
the the treasurer of the permanent
firefighters of New Hampshire you don't
really have a you have a fiduciary
responsibility to the organization but
you're not in a policymaking role and
you're also and you're also employed by
them yeah and yeah right if you're
employed you may be the janitor for that
organization here you would be yeah I
think it I think that the particularly
with this conflict on special interest I
think the language in the Shen Amendment
is a little clearer and it says pretty
much the same thing except well it
narrower yeah it's less broad
mhm so if you're the treasurer of the
organization and you're a legislator
shouldn't you recuse
yes yes but this the this says if you're
the you have to be an employee of that
organization if you're the bartender at
the Sweeny post it's not a
you shouldn't need to recuse yourself
that
right that's how I read it that if you
were employed
by yeah you've got you've got to recuse
and and I think that would include the
janitor
and and that would broaden who would
recuse representative
V just a a language issue here if it
were read is employed by and is acting
as an agent for an
organization that might uh be the
original intent which one are you
referring to please
copy
the okay please line 20
20 instead of the or make it an and is
that what you're suggesting
representative V yes I think that's
unnecessarily restrictive because
particularly for nonprofits there's a
whole lot of volunteer board members
that are not
employed I I I
would significantly disagree with that
at making that
change I was just mentioning the fact
that that would change substantially the
meaning of the sentence it would narrow
back to where we were in the sheen yes
make it I'm also curious and narrower
because you'd have to be employed by yes
it would I'm also curious as to why on
line 18 of the document just handed to
us it talks about 14- C colon
3- a whereas in the shean amendment line
23 is 14- C colon 4- a so
which what what's being changed here I
guess is my
question
is that a
typo representative nutting Wong oh I
would just guess that's a typo because
in a line 16 it says by inserting after
section
three so I would just guess that that's
a
typo except that it continues back onto
the back page two of the of that
Amendment
I I'd like to go back to the idea that
it if the if the complaint was that it
was too
broad this in fact makes it more
broad I guess that's open to
interpretation and that's where we have
a problem I don't think it is I don't
think it is I think if you're if you're
expanding by just saying someone has to
be employed
by I think rather than the the sheen
Amendment which just said that you had
to have a fiduciary obligation in that
company you're bringing in an awful lot
more people I don't think it is subject
to interpretation I think it's very
clearly broadening who would who
potentially could would have to
recuse
is that
not are there any other changes here um
besides
the so we are taking out the special in
well it's written special interest but
apparently that's
not going to be there what what would
replace special
interest the definition that's already
in the sheen
Amendment and I'll and I'll throw out
another
question are any of these things could
if there's word smithing that needs to
be done if there is is that something
that can be taken
up
um when it when it crosses
over I I'm I'm tossing that out as
a open question uh if there are phrases
that I I understand the goal of trying
to
um acquest to the concern of the Ethics
Committee on the broadening section but
I don't think this language does that
but if there is other
language that could be brought to the
Senate that
did um
narrow that that's another
possibility so Mr chairman you're
suggesting that if we pass the Shen
amendment that you would not be opposed
to um further looking at
this thank you never
um it very rarely does something of this
nature um go go unattended by the other
body um either direction so so it would
be um it would be rare um former
chairman of of the Ethics Committee and
a former strong member of the Ethics
Committee will be seeing this on that
side so I'm sure there'll be
wordsmithing done over there yeah I'm
sure there will be I I have no doubt
that there would be
um quite honestly that was one of the
benefits I felt of of adopting 99.9% of
the language from the Ethics Committee I
thought it would Li eliminate or limit
the amount of um word smithing that went
on on the Senate
side but I'm not saying that that that
passing the sheen
Amendment precludes the opportunity for
someone in the Senate to change
phraseology I I'm I'm just saying this
is the best option we have in front of
us right now uh seems to be this the
shien um Amendment and I'm ready
to um move forward on the
OTP thank you Dennis Malloy yep
um so
this but I I want to ask uh
representative wall this is then
in not in line with what the Ethics
Committee voted on yesterday I want to
be clear about that or or just
or suggested in in your
meeting to to to accept the
Shen yes may I respond thank you um
again there was very very brief time
given to this in ethics um by the former
speaker of the house and the
chairman of the Ethics Committee as well
as former Judiciary Committee Member
representative former representative
house um Ned Gordon and Donna saitech
and um they were in agreement that the
they claimed they believe that the Shen
amendment is too broad that it's very
difficult to enforce
um that it would exclude too many people
but if that's the case perhaps it makes
sense to let the other bodies see
this and determine for themselves and if
they need to amend it based on what
we've also said from the Ethics
Committee then so be it and then go to
Committee of
conference that may
represent or comment yeah uh thank you
think then that
perhaps I would be amable to sending
this over to the Senate and uh letting
them work that out it seems like the
general consensus here is that they'll
take a good look at it thank you and
tear it apart or do it that's my that's
my part or or op
op yeah sorry thank you and Mr chairman
I think that's exactly where we've come
to in our discussion that you know there
wasn't a lot of effort and not I
shouldn't say that there wasn't a lot of
time being given to this because there
wasn't time yesterday and
um and this was our first exposure to
what uh chairman Gordon has Preferred so
I think given our time also and the fact
that we do have another chance in the
Senate um then we I I suggest we support
the Shan Amendment thank you
you have your light do you you have a
comment representative
fo you still have your light there you
go any further comment before
we go to a
vote seeing none one more represent I
would just like to say thank you for the
uh conversation about this today having
been exposed to this for the very first
time uh I think what little we what we
talked about here I think I'm clear
about the what's what we need to do and
what so I appreciate that thank you
thank you for your comments um that
that's actually from my point of view
that's one of the benefits of having
substitutes come in um because quite
often it's a forest for the trees
situation and and it is good to get
fresh eyes on a situation yes thank you
and I appreciate the fact that we've had
really decent uh respectful open
discussion on this even though we're not
really wholeheartedly in favor um at
least everyone's been brought on board
so everyone understands where we are and
what possibilities there can be so thank
you well as you know as former chair of
this this is what this committee does um
it's it's not
a it's never been a committee as far as
I've been here and you've been here
longer than I it's never been a
committee that did anything except um
welcome the comments of other members
and weigh them fairly and um and openly
so um it's your leadership that I I'm
following here so that's fine I can't
thank you enough for
that um with that U seeing no other no
other hands or um I would ask clerk to
call the rooll we're dealing with the
OTP um on the amend Amendment um the
shean amendment 2023
2326 H to remind everyone what we're
voting on so is this just a roll call on
the amendment roll call on the
amendment I suppose I could no I would
let's do a roll call all right roll call
on Amendment uh
23268 uh representative Shen
yes representative
sellers representative sellers yes thank
you representative
Maguire the clerk votes yes
representative Vose yes representative
mcarter yes representative
tyranny yes representative wall yes
representative nut nutting Wong sorry I
say
nothing representative
turot yes representative
Richards are you you're okay yeah okay
so there's no I don't think there's
anyone here for
her representative Malloy
yes representative William Dolan well
that's that's actually the replacement
no no I don't know no representan
not here either
okay uh representative monteo
representative Fox
yes okay and the chair why do we do that
all the time yes chair votes
yes 13 yay it's unanimous okay 13 yay
um ordinarily I would would ask if
anyone wanted oh now we're going I'm
sorry yeah now we're going to uh House
Bill 301 as amended um is there any
discussion further discussion I think we
beat this particular
horse um yes representative W thank you
Mr chairman I just want to reiterate
that I I hope nobody thinks we're just
passing this off onto the Senate uh I
been in committees before where people
say well this really isn't good enough
or whatever so we'll let the Senate take
care of it I again we've really worked
hard on this and we'll see where we can
go thank you I I appreciate those
comments greatly uh representative Salis
yeah process do you have to make a mo
someone need to make a motion to a pass
as
amended she
pass and it was
seconded
okay um with that I'll ask the clerk
colero on we're now dealing with um
House Bill 301 as
amended okay uh representative Shen yes
representative sers yes representative
Maguire yes clerk votes yes
representative Vose yes representative
mcarter yes representative tyy yes
representative wall yes representative n
W yes representative
terot yes representative Malloy
yes representative Fox
yes chairman Hill
yes so we have a 13
unanimous thank you everyone 13 to
nothing um ordinarily what I was going
to say is ordinarily I Would S entertain
the idea of consent calendar but I'm
fairly certain this is not going to be
anything that would stay on the consent
calendar so I'm going to suggest that it
remain on the regular
calendar without
objection
okay yeah um thank you very much uh with
that I'll close the hearing on House
Bill 30 uh the executive session on 301
um we're past the time but this is a
quick one
for what's the
number7 thank you uh
157 um opening the exact session on
House Bill 157 um this is dealing with
the joint committee on legislative
facilities and sexual harassment
policies
um representative shean would you like
to offer a
motion yes I like to move interim
study uh representative Sheen moves
interim study second by representative
wall um would you like to discuss your
motion yes
yes go ahead okay I wasn't prepared but
yes so um this was a another bill that
we've uh been working on um with help
from Mr Terry PA and um
researchers and it seems that this needs
a little more work before we can put it
for a boat thank you um I'm not sure if
it's something that
uh that
are either our house attorney or would
like to speak to or you I'm getting head
shakes back there that's good um so from
my point of view my and and feel free to
correct me if I'm wrong um this this is
a situation that um is being dealt with
um
internally um from a more comprehensive
um Avenue uh the the dealings of House
Bill 157 primarily dealt with
legislators um and we are of the
understanding that um that it's being
broadened um more to fall in line with
um house uh with House and Senate staff
as well so it would make sense to me um
that if we set this aside in interim
study rather than
itl um it would allow the vehicle to
exist and the house position would not
um be an itl which would preclude
further legislation coming up in this
same um area so it just seems to me to
be a a logical um step to take and allow
um our our Dream Team to uh put together
something for uh for January or February
I think um and then we'll we'll still
have the the door available the
opportunity available to um submit
legislation if we need to so with that
um unless there's further
discussion seeing none um I'll ask the
clerk to call the rooll for for um an
interim study motion on House Bill
157 okay interim study motion on Bill
157 uh representative Sheen yes
representative sers yes representative
Maguire yes clerk votes yes
representative V yes representative
mcarter yes representative tyrany yes
representative wall yes representative
nutting Wong yes representative turot
yes representative Malloy yes
representative Fox yes and the chair
Hill yes yes
okay 13 Y no Nays unanimous interim uh
interim study very agreeable lot today
um that closes our work for today um as
far as what was on the schedule I would
like to um the thank the substitutes for
um your assistance and your input um it
was greatly
appreciated um we do I would like to
talk to the rest of the committee though
we um next week have an interesting
situation coming up um we have a retain
bill Senate Bill 84 still um let this be
a lesson to you that will become chairs
in the future um retain bills are not
always your friend and especially retain
bills that that um last until near the
deadline date um because you get
contacted by virtually everyone that
wants to add a non gerine Amendment onto
your retain bill so as of the moment we
have um we we purposely hung on to um
Senate Bill 84 in order to take any
information or input from the special
committee on committees and that it was
picked that this would be the vehicle to
take that direction from the special
committee on committees um that's why
we've been waiting as long as we have
that has been forthcoming in fact our
own um Vice chair prepared the amendment
from the special committee on committees
where she also sits so that was going to
be a replace all bill um amendment that
was going to replace everything that's
on Senate bill now Senate Bill 84
now we now have three other um
amendments non- gerain amendments that
we need hearing for next
Wednesday I'm
hopeful um and I'm looking over to see
I'm hopeful that the Amendments come to
us early enough that we can submit our
entry into the
calendar they are all
here
okay no we should have okay we have two
we we need three or we need four
total um
yeah the the pro the problem just so
you're aware is that in order to enter
it into the calendar as an as a non-gain
hearing for next week we need the number
of the amendment that comes from
OS um that's what we've been pushing for
and we we're a half hour from the
deadline here so um once we get that
number then we can submit it and and I'm
assuming the four amendments that we
have are going to be relatively quick um
I think I've schedule 10 minutes apart
here um just I think we'll be able to
knock through all of them and I actually
think we'll be able to knock out the
entire amended um Bill fairly
quickly but it does mean one additional
trip for everybody to conquer um I think
it'll be 10 o00 next
Wednesday and and then we'll be done for
this Academic Year but I thought I'd
keep you up to date with where we are
and why we are in the position that
we're
in there any questions about that or any
concerns or comments
if it slips a day
um if it slips a day I will not be in
attendance I have jury
duty um okay um as I
said if it slips a day from the 8th of
November I don't think any of these are
of any great controversy that um we you
will be missed but I don't think it's
going to affect uh the outcome of these
seems Seems fair to say um thank you for
the updated notice though but you're
okay for is everyone else okay for that
date the8 all right sounds good it'll it
we should be out of here I would think
if we start at 10: we should be out of
here at 11: that's my
guess all right thanks very much I
appreciate it with that I'm
closing um I have one question not no no
not for everybody else just for you what
are we going to do with thank
you